one of the most poorly titled movies of
all time the first purge invalidated
five years of me referring to this movie
as the first purge however unlike the
original purge this one came out
relatively close to when the story takes
place
the movie is set in 2016. if you want to
see me explain the entire timeline watch
this video but being set closer to the
release date affords this movie an
interesting opportunity to incorporate
current events for the first time
like how isaiah has a poster for another
poorly titled movie halloween 2018 in
his room
this is part advertising for blumhouse
who wanted to hype up their other big
release for that year and part
foreshadowing as isaiah and his loved
ones would hide in the closet at the end
of the movie just like laurie strode did
in halloween to learn about the other
references and hidden meanings in the
first purge stick around to the end of
this video
[Music]
there aren't really any decent masks for
sale for the first purge for whatever
reason
so i'm gonna go bear for this one
welcome to things you missed the initial
three purge films were both written and
directed by james demonico but for this
prequel he'd stay on his screenwriter
while tasking gerard mcmurray with
directing duties
subtle is probably not the word best
used to describe any purge film but you
could at least make the argument that
the themes are subtle in 1-3
especially if you've seen my videos
analyzing them mcmurray decided to take
a more
direct approach the poster for this
movie and the lines said during this
scene are very obvious jabs at the
united states white house administration
during the time this movie was made
whereas the previous movies depicted the
nffa
as an alternates to real-life political
parties as you know we're not here to
talk about the obvious details in this
movie we're here to talk about the
things you missed so let's get in
to the things you missed here's the
things you missed screen
[Music]
one detail i found interesting was how
the nffa chief of staff intentionally
sends his mercenaries to purge in
low-income areas this makes it appear as
if the lower class is out for blood
which almost directly leads into the
beginning of the original movie where a
group of affluent purgers hunt down an
innocent homeless man for no reason
other than the fact that he's homeless
we've also seen that the nffa likes to
use statistics to make it seem like the
purge is helping reduce crime during the
rest of the year
unfortunately the nffa website which was
updated with statistics and additional
lore to promote the purge movie releases
in the past has its weakest iteration
for the first purge there's basically no
new information here but perhaps
more importantly at the beginning of
this movie we see how this data was
skewed the scene suggests that they're
doing their research about crime
behavior using crazies and addicts as
opposed to the general population
this is a tactic that they use to craft
their own narrative they want to make it
seem like the purge is the answer for
the nation's problems but many of their
opposers see through the bs and protest
at the sign up stations where citizens
can volunteer to participate in the
purge experiment in exchange for
financial compensation
the conflict draws in many news stations
including one called krxjnews a station
that has appeared in the tv show psych
and in the marvel cinematic universe it
seems it's appeared in a couple of other
shows as well
is this a coincidence i don't think so
there are about 35 000 possible
combinations that start with either k
or w i tried googling a number of random
combinations and surprisingly they all
seemed to be taken but krxj was the only
one i found that yielded a fictional
entity after doing a little digging i
realized that prop designer daniel
collumbi has also designed for a few
marvel movies i'm guessing that's the
connection and the answer to
this pointless question the sign up
stations also give away blue flowers to
those who sign up to participate
batisius the official flower of the
experiment
they represent rebirth this explains the
origin of a through line in each of the
purge movies which become a sign of
support for the purge
and your blue flowers tell me that you
support the purge the main antagonist
this time is the original nffa chief of
staff
arlo sabian if you've seen my other
purge episodes you know that sabian is a
name that comes up in every purge movie
which is perhaps just a symptom of the
fact that they're all written by james
demonico who likes to have a character
named sabian in all of his work the
other james demonico trademark is staten
island where the purge experiment is
going to take place
this location appears on a tv screen in
the preceding purge movies and the two
non-purge movies that he's directed are
both set there but not far from where
this is taking place our main character
naya leads a protest against the
controversial experiment
one of the signs reads the 28th is a hit
crime this suggests that the purge is
being considered as the 28th amendment
to the u.s constitution which is
confirmed in the original iteration of
the website
but i think this movie creates an
interesting metaphor for the
constitution
naya and isaiah live at a building
called the park towers let's pretend
that building is the us constitution
it's an old building
it has a lot of leaks that have come up
over the years the people that live
there have a lot of issues with it
the problem is the manager is never in
and isn't much help with fixing these
issues anyways our characters are
minorities and they live on the 14th
floor it just so happens that the 14th
amendment deals with equal protection of
the laws and is often used to fight
racial discrimination
this is fitting because the nffa hires
modern factions of racist groups such as
the kkk and aryan nations to go into
staten island and purge the main bad guy
whose name is
general smiley has a gold armband very
similar to the red
nazi armband you might see generals
wearing an old photographs they attack
the entire building floor by floor
on the second floor a couple of armed
citizens fight back against them
as it turns out the second amendment is
the rights to bear arms something
citizens are reminded of in the form of
a huge billboard the text at the bottom
says paid for by uaro political victory
fund
i have no idea what uaro is but if you
look up political victory fund you'll
find a bunch of stuff about the nra who
are stated at the beginning of the movie
to be supporting the new founding
fathers
the new founding fathers rising in polls
with the nra now endorsing them
and supporting them financially with
large donations to the nffa warchief
the implication is that the purge is
fueled by money this whole thing
happened because the nffa values money
more than it values the lives of its
citizens
they have monetized and incentivized
murder
goes away from their money the police
officers who are keeping an eye on this
protest don't seem too enthused but with
names like forbes and
sachs maybe it's because they are in on
it as well
[Music]
staten island was chosen as the site of
the experiment partially because it was
home to a number of street gangs one of
which was led by a man named dimitri who
surprisingly operates out of a community
center named after jamaican activist
marcus garvey you've probably noticed
that this movie picks up where election
year left off comparing the anti-purge
movement to the american civil rights
movement
the first purge is as usual a lot less
subtle about it
there's one point where naya even claims
that she sees the purge as a way that
the government is trying to keep
minorities down
in election year joe's deli was the
center of the community and it displayed
the photos of several civil rights
leaders
in the first purge the community center
has some of these same photos
literally we see the same exact picture
for martin luther king jr and a very
similar picture for malcolm x i don't
know if this was just the production
trying to save a few bucks on props but
it actually makes me wonder if joe from
election year might have been a
youngster at this very community center
and took these photos with him when he
went to dc to start the deli we know he
has been a part of gang activity before
told you i ain't no saint everybody's
got a past
the other photos include civil rights
figures jesse jackson marcus garvey and
thurgood marshall and the cork board
celebrates athletes who broke the color
barrier like jesse owens muhammad ali
and
jackie robinson robinson came up with
the brooklyn dodgers playing first base
but faced a lot of adversity because he
was the first african
american to play in mlb as opposed to
the negro leagues brooklyn is right next
to staten island and there's a scene
later in the film where a black man is
purged by white police officers just in
front of first base at a stadium with
advertisements for the purge experiment
displayed in the outfield
so it feels like the movie is telling us
that the purge gave bad people the
opportunity to undo the progress made by
people like jackie robinson
and while we're talking about sports i
have to say there was a huge missed
opportunity by the wardrobe department
they gave this guy taz and eli manning
jersey but they should have given him
number 17 for plaxico burris seeing as
how taz later gets shot in the leg and
plaxico burris infamously shot himself
in the leg at a night's club
gotta love the character of dimitri
though i mean how many powerful
gangsters have time to also be an
inspiring community basketball coach
when it comes to gangster's name dimitri
this guy is probably in my top two or
three in dimitri's office he has a giant
artwork of ben franklin as seen on the
100
bill in universe the reason he has it is
simply because he likes money but there
are many shots where the eye peeks
through as if it is watching and spying
on him ben franklin is one of america's
original founding fathers and in the
film the government is controlled by a
party called the new founding fathers
and they are notorious for spying on the
citizens whether it be through
surveillance cameras recording contact
lenses or attack drones
another symbol for this can be seen in
the party scene where a giant eyeball is
passed around in the crowd
partygoers wear animal masks and makeup
such as foxes lions leopards and cows i
think i spotted a wendigo in there too
this is a way of foreshadowing the
predator-prey relationship between the
nffa and the public and speaking of
masks there's a scene where naya is
trapped by a guy in a creepy babydoll
mask
the repurposing of a baby doll seems to
be a nod to the remote control camera
created by charlie sandin
in the original purge quit playing with
timmy and come
help me set the table since this is a
prequel there are some things that we've
come to know about the world of the
purge that seemingly haven't been
instituted yet i noticed that the
vehicles have new york license plates
where in later entries the nffa have
instituted a uniform license plate for
the u.s
that says a nation reborn this was also
before the u.s postal service was
replaced with nffa mail
another difference is that the color of
the emergency broadcast screen was red
instead of the usual blue
director gerard mcmurray kind of flipped
the script when it comes to color
other than this one graphic at the very
end of election year the nffa is always
associated with the color blue
perhaps the nffa intentionally chose
light blue so that the public associates
them with the good guy
think about pop culture good guys blue
bad guys red but mcmurray uses lights in
this movie to reveal the true
allegiances of the characters in
addition to the red emergency broadcast
there's the nffa headquarters the
hunters that try to purge isaiah and
sabian steps into the red light after
revealing the true sinister intentions
of the experiment
isaiah has blue contacts nia's church is
blue and dimitri's car has a blue
underglow dimitri's office is also blue
but when the assassins enter the room
they come from the lone red lights in
the corner
the office also has a picture of a man
in red boxing against a man in blue
the purge is like a punch in the face
from the governments to those that
oppose them
interestingly skeletor is the only
character whose contact lenses are
purple a combination of red and blue
the bystanders who stay home are green
and the looters are usually green and
occasionally orange
it's possible that there's also a
political side to mcmurray's decision to
color code
in the u.s green is representative of
the third party so maybe that's why
green is used to portray those that seem
to be neutral the artwork in dimitri's
office is also representative of the
differing ways that naya and dmitry deal
with their problems in one scene
naya confronts him because she was upset
that her younger brother was getting
involved in his operation
she criticizes him for what his gang has
done to their community as they argue
dimitri is standing in front of these
two boxers he solves his problems with
aggression
the artwork behind anaya also depicts a
boxer but he is sitting in the dark
thinking and quietly reflecting
naya solves her issues with her head
isaiah had been hurt while selling
illegal substances on the street for
dimitri
naya is vocally against him doing this
and their apartment is covered with
signage that says drug free zone
and no smoking dimitri's gangs rule the
streets but the apartment acts as a safe
haven for isaiah i also noticed that
their building looks very similar to the
example of low-income housing that dante
bishop shows on tv during election year
election year takes place 24 years later
so these images illustrate how
nothing ever actually improved while the
nffa was in power comparing the
technology from the first purge to
election year highlights one of the many
frustrating things about the purge
franchise which is that technology
actually seems to get worse as time goes
on election year has a lot of tech that
feels old even today
the coolest gadget in the series is
probably the first purge's video contact
lenses which are actually based on a
real concept that sony has filed patents
for but we're still years and years away
from seeing them in practice
as i record this video in 2021 now i'm
gonna get to the end of this movie and
why it makes no sense but before i do
it's the part of the video where i've
gotta air them out a little bit
during the robbery at this cash for gold
place why does the store owner only have
a security shade over one window and i
like how he keeps his neon signs on so
he can advertise the criminals that he
has valuables
also there's no way dimitri would have
survived this crash but he's perfectly
fine a couple minutes later
one thing i did find interesting was
that the mercenaries that sabian sent in
the purge to give the appearance that
people had participated are hidden in
everyday vehicles like a plumber's truck
and a veteran transport van now the
ending of the movie is a little bit
unconventional with dimitri's help naya
isaiah and the others are able to ward
off general smiley skeletor and the rest
of the bad guys and the purge ends now
usually at the end of a movie you see
that the character has changed somehow
we call it
the character arc but when naya asks
dimitri what's next he tells her
no we fight you which kind of goes
against the message of the movie which
has basically shown us that fighting
basically nearly destroyed the community
so it's kind of like a bad guys win
anyway scenario because conflict is
exactly what the nffa wants this ending
also might be suggesting that dimitri
was kind of like the start of the
resistance a seed that would grow into
the anti-nffa group that we meet later
on in the purge anarchy as more people
in different cities get involved that
group is probably not the most notable
resistance in the purge franchise though
i would give that honor to the group we
see in another poorly titled installment
the purge tv series
so join me in the next episode of things
you missed where i'll be breaking down
the
entire show remember to subscribe to
cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell and select all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive if you don't
want to be purged
stay home if you go out for essentials
wear a mask